merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre de la santé et de
la prévention monsieur ministre au CHU
de Nantes comme dans de nombreuses
autres établissements hospitaliers de
France les services d'urgence
pédiatriques sont débordés l'origine
principale de cette saturation est liée
à la forte circulation depuis la fin du
mois d'octobre de la bronchiolite cette
infection respiratoire virale qui touche
surtout les enfants de moins de deux ans
si cette épidémie est fréquente elle est
cette année particulièrement précoce et
virulente cette pathologie est dans la
majorité des cas bénigne mais cet
automne santé publique France pointe un
nombre de passages aux urgences et
d'hospitalisation pour bronchiolite très
élevée
principaux très supérieur à ceux
observer au pic épidémie épidémique
depuis plus de 10 ans la situation
inquiète profondément les professionnels
de santé et les familles et ceci a juste
titre le gouvernement a d'ailleurs
rapidement réagi avec le déclenchement
du plan hors-san mercredi dernier et
avec l'intensification des campagnes
d'information rappelant l'importance des
gestes barrières pour protéger les
enfants de cette infection ma question
s'articulera ainsi autour de deux
aspects le préventif et le curatif
monsieur le ministre alors que désormais
votre ministère comprend officiellement
la prévention dans son périmètre n'y
a-t-il pas un changement de méthode à
fournir dans l'anticipation de la
survenance des épidémie saisonnière en
termes d'éducation et d'information et
je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
Paro